Next, we will look at techniques that make independence instructions easier for
a processor to find. So ideal processor would find them because it is able to
look at an infinite number of instructions, potentially, but
the real processor can only see so many instructions ahead. So it actually
doesn't see that there are independent instructions further down the code.
We will really look at two techniques. One is instruction scheduling for
simple branch-free sequences of instructions.
Then we will look at techniques specific to loops, such as loop unrolling, and
how they interact with the instruction scheduling, and then,
we will briefly look at the more powerful technique called trace scheduling.